leider was geht ab hier soll marx und
jetzt willkommen zu einer runde gestern
mit challenge mitarbeiter moody s k oder
und wir machen heute folgende change
warum ich überhaupt so anfang ich wollte
einfach zeigen wie wir hier zocken wir
wollen sebastian ist ja da wie unschwer
erkennen können esra und wir haben wir
ungefähr dass zocker paradies aufgebaut
also hier meinen pc meinen bildschirm
sebastians wäre was ins pc und wir
sitzen uns so direkt gegenüber all
diesen großen und suchten ja und mit ihr
das toll oder egal dann gehen jetzt mal
in die runde und wir spielen heute eine
challenge bist du hier hätten erklärst
genau das hier ist ein tolles handy
schneller immer wenn max falckenberg
kommt wirken dieser würfel app gewürfelt
haben zwei würfel klicken hier drauf
acht sekunden muss jetzt abwarten 23.45
uhr hatte ich bin mir selbst ja ich bin
schon schlinge papier nochmal eine 6 1 2
3 4 5 6
also max muss immer die zeit die gehör
finden auf dem konto kommt absetzen wo
er möchte muss einen knatsch denn die
werden übrigens dieselbe change auch für
den kanal voll mein bruder machen
allerdings in einem anderen spiel modus
ihre ersten überraschungen von daher
checkt einfach aus fünf sekunden 1234
doppeln 6 7 8 9 10 und weiter okay das
war manchmal dresdner darf nämlich nicht
weitergehen
wer muss auf exakt diesen block stehen
weil ich dann kann ich auch ein bisschen
risiko und die die weißen flecken in
eigentlich schon weil ich sowieso 92
wert euro
bitter das tier deshalb ist das krasse
eingerüstet musste musste mich dann
umschauen und gucken
in der nähe ist bevor doch ein comeback
draufgehen ja und wenn ich drauf stehe
sowieso branche sowieso da kannst du
nichts machen dann siehst du nur dem
schicksal ins auge sieht es leider nicht
runter drücken runter bevor nämlich
gesehen gut gesehen ich auch schon mal
die und jetzt neu und und 10 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 10
oh mein gott diese change ist so hart
doch tatsächlich sehr schön gesprungen
aber sein können aber ich habe 401 wobei
das geht klar hervor ich meist jede
runde bekommt so circa 400 konsum kommt
sobald 2000 um irgendwelche effektvoll
okay sagen immer freut macht ja keinen
sinn fall fall voll arbeitet aber ist in
der hinsicht nimmer kann aber auch
spring sagen stadt springen weil spring
ist englisch die feder also bei seinem
sprung sogar und und hier 1234 film hast
da sagst du hast ja super fcz muss
aufpassen sich nicht mehr dass ich aus
dem leben hatte nämlich vor glaube ich
aber dass sie kommt mit genau das ist
alles was zählt dabei aus der nächste
es war aber nicht mein job hier und eine
31 234 sehr schleichend super für dich
und überlebte das alter risky ok 123456
hast eingesehen war leider wollte
eigentlich zudem dahin gehen wo alte
papa nicht dass dem kann man nicht mal
fachleute 520 es ist für die challenge
eigentlich echt gut
ich hatte auch bisher nicht so die super
langen zeiten besser auf einmal 10
das geht eigentlich auch vielleicht
sollte ich einfach runter gehen ohne auf
konkrete ch gegner auf euch allen rohren
vielleicht machen aber den haushalt
extrem wenig
musst du halt wissen am ende zählt die
performances leute mehr klappt und wer
wenig konz hat der wird im deathmatch
nach liebt geliebt genau mit dem ein
oder anderen verzauberten der mutanten
ist gar nicht schlimm anklickt damit
kommen vielleicht freunde zu denen hier
eltern post hat noch der beste von
schlechten sex ist welche rolle kommt ja
ja ja okay und wir machen wir bereit
noch bereit und 51 23 45 und seid ihr
mit dem ok energy systems abwarten weil
den von mir und da ist direkt 2 3 4 5 6
1 aber ich bin zufrieden als er 1263 in
der zweiten runde wie soll ich da jemals
aufholen ist sich aber ich habe einfach
da ein team welches am ende hatten aber
du spielst die change gut finde ich also
ich meine ich bin absolut okay 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 und weiter du musst auch die
ganzen 80 kunden abwarten
3 millisekunden zu früh 1 auch zwei oder
geschlagen
ich lebe ja ja ja ich bin auch fein
gerieben blieb beim 1 1
die abgeleiteten machen müssen so weit
herunter geschlagen der gleichheit
erkennen steht ja nicht genau
per definition die funktionelle jung
riskiert nun eine oder zehn 12345
6 7 8 9 10
ok stabiler stabil wie in ein stabiler
alle werden dafür hätten die bestellte
herunterzählt eigentlich immer wenn wir
zählen irgendwelche gangster musik im
hintergrund legt ohne witz zehn sekunden
und darf sehr schön geworfen press1 23
45 ich muss echt aufpassen die antifa
nur noch 31 abstand ich muss jetzt ein
bisschen risiko 641 ist aber in ordnung
geht geht dann kann man schon spengler
damit würde damit kann man nicht wissen
kann man spielen man kann schon was was
machen ja du musst halt bisschen
taktisch spielen auf jeden fall könnte
es klappen
ich bin übrigens bisschen krank leute
finden das der fall dass er ich denke
warum klingt der song natal so nasa als
wäre ihm im raum mit meiner 47 dann
klingt er so nah sei als wäre ein
amerikanischer aus körper na ja und
warum gehört dieser rap hat eine
freundin
okay leute glaube damit an breaking 3
ich glaube ich lasse mich bei schaffens
2 doch noch eine mit an den schatten ich
muss nicht aber weißt du wenn ich halt
immer weiter drauf ankommt dann
vermutlich irgendwie schafft 11
ja alles schön drauf ja das ist ob man
ja dann kann glaube ich was anfangen ich
muss mal schauen wie die gegner
den kann ich wahrscheinlich zum beispiel
klatschen zu wollen will ich sagen
wollte sie nicht mehr aufpassen dass
jetzt kein voll damit kirche ident
dürfte dann nicht runter kommen sonst
sind durch die herzen der weg der dürfte
recht nicht unterkommen
ja oh ja oh ja das macht ihr alter an
musikwoche blöcke 38 jahren das neue
battle ok ard der katze glauben
enchanted das war dieser aspekt ist der
online part entscheidend das heißt eben
nicht allzu viele konz das könnte
klappen bekommt vielleicht vielleicht
jetzt findet ein schwert yao er wird in
die mangel genommen
außerdem klicks auf dem u-boot dessen
bastert habe ein paar alte hut sein und
hemmt ja sehr guter chef sehr schön
leistungspunkte und entscheiden uns drin
und der andere ist jetzt richtig
naja weil der jetzt kommt er an euro
abgezogen
das hat richtig gezogen okay okay leute
ich bin ich hab dich mal kurz noch
einmal kurzzeitig dürftig dürfte es
schaffen kannst du jetzt auch endlich im
juni gut ich weiß nicht wie viele
künstler letztendlich hatte aber der
hatte in der 2001 bisschen eine menge
extra herzen
naja es ist schön natürlich jede menge
extras verletzter deshalb besser
okay kein schwein ich wollte gerade
sagen keine feier aspect das tut weh
robert block
sie bekommen fünf rainer kommt brocken
stehst du nicht schlecht aber die
rebellierenden jetzt kann die
rüstungsgegner erst mal ein bisschen
laufen kannst du gut zumindest mal dass
das ende näher ging dagegen ich weiß
ehrlich gesagt nicht was ich hier groß
machen oder auch auf auch kurz ich will
kurz weglaufen kürzlich ein halt echt
gerne bogen gegen den typen
da ist noch eine menge luft ich mir kurz
den holen wir besorgt schnell wieder
mitnehmen stabilen kommt ja es kommen
aber zwei hinter mir okay das ist halt
der obhut der hinter mir
weil der mich wahrscheinlich als größte
bedrohung identifiziert
harry potter haben fire ein er habe ich
gesehen nicht dass jetzt wie so viele
andere zweifelten oder mich hinter mir
ja den habe ich bin habe ich wirklich
direkt mitnehmen mitnimmt genau mit dem
pott kommen er habe aber und beamt sehr
schön perfekt und dias mit der software
19 sekunden 10 10 jähriger hab ich
glaube das wird nichts aber den undercut
ja auch noch holen
also ich komme zumindest nicht mit der
idee an rein gerade das das stimmt auto
der andere hat auch nur mäßige rüstung
nicht der rechts da oben der länder
müssen aber der andere haut vorfall so
der muss schon auch irgendwas verkehrt
sein bogen also der macht mir ein halb
herzen mit mit bogen der session wird
infiniti draufhaben der machbar
erscheint ja ich kann die frage auch
nicht aufheben erhöht werden
dann sollte ich dementsprechend ok fast
auf null runter der homo denn jetzt geht
auf mich herunter gleich von yahoo
und jetzt wo ich mir sie durch wollte
jetzt abgehen auf den po kontrolleure
damit habe ich hab' ich habe seine 180
tausend drin einzige chance der wird
aber extra wahrscheinlich schon dass sie
noch keinen dollar fließen lassen
egal was durch seine muss durchziehen
aber jetzt mit fire aspect auch
ästhetisch ich hab' ich habe definitiv
um stimmt damit kann sie ein bisschen
ärger machen aber die fahne ist ein gold
ab ich habe habe auch noch noch weitere
sachen die ich ansetzen kann der auch
noch lange gehabt dann kann man ja auch
einiges machen ja stimmt aber ich würde
sollte es jetzt durchziehen
ich habe er hat einen anderen plan ok
bis sehr hoch was hat ihren kranken ball
vor
münchen jetzt angel cappa hochziehen und
mit voll damit städten dem bauch oder
auch nicht dass die leute das tut weh
selbst erforderlich bekommen hier kann
dann kommt ans wasser ich glaube der
dude hat keinen bogen das heißt du
kannst du denn so sein wie sein schwert
auch sein mag kann ich ihm glaube ich
einiges rheingold manchmal geschäften
viel schaden es schwer bei mir ich nicht
gelegentlich kein kriegen man warum ist
veranstalter auf der bogen der punch ist
gar nicht so leicht nicht gut bestellt
aber der bürger power lob am 23 ich
glaube er macht ein herz und schoss
verbogen dem echt ein bisschen weh tun
ab jetzt jetzt hier live
wir müssen bewusst machen sie durch eure
zurückgebracht caterer hat das tut mir
leid
hinterher komm schon a hts nicht
angezeigt ich glaube nicht mehr drei
herzen 33 einheiten mit das war richtig
klasse alter knapp 1 endlos lange runde
ich hoffe es hat euch trotzdem gefallen
wir sehen uns dann beim nächsten mal
wieder macht's gut und bis dahin